the mayor of El Paso who is a Democrat
which is very bizarre to me but who
knows uh he went on CNN and uh you know
basically uh he's not happy that uh
Biden didn't get to see what he should
have seen
mayor one question has been about what
the president didn't see because from
our reports on the ground reporters were
with him he didn't actually come face to
face with any of the migrants there and
we know that there are hundreds of
migrants of course we've seen them
sleeping on the streets of El Paso so
did he get a sufficient view of the
humanitarian crisis aspect of this
well
he didn't
he did I could have played you more of
the clip but he didn't because they
cleaned it up before he got there he
then went to the Salvation Army over
there in El Paso and I think it was the
militant wing of the Salvation Army if
I'm not mistaken that's an Austin Powers
joke if you're following uh he went
there and just try to make sense of what
we may have to play this one twice
please make sense this is at the
Salvation Army in El Paso he's there for
immigration he walks up to one of the
people there over at the Salvation Army
and someone explained to me what he's
saying here
all right we got it we got to play this
one again because it's a little hard to
hear but it's really important so he's
at the Salvation Army he is told he is
at the Salvation Army he's meeting
people from the Salvation Army he walks
up to that man and says that he quote
spent some time with the Secret Service
in Poland and Ukraine and then that man
from The Salvation Army has to oh well
my god well that's play it again please
myself
as Connor just pointed out you know the
guy did have a big S badge on his
shoulder there so it's possible that Joe
Biden thought that meant Secret Service
it probably meant Salvation Army but
like there's something wrong with him
there is something wrong with it well
there's a lot of things wrong with this
man but like literally does not know
where he is okay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]